[Müzik]
bak Doğa uyanıyor Hadi kalk bu coşkuya
katılalım Asırlardır
[Müzik]
Uz biry insanların kutladığı bu en eski
Bayramı Nevruz'u kutlayalım
[Müzik]
Bugün 21 Mart gece gündüze eşit insan
insana baharı müjdeliyor Toprak karanlık
kıştan çıkıp yemyeşil bir bahara
berekete bolluğa merhaba diyor Nevruz
yani yeni gün
nesilden nesile aktarılan bir bayram ve
gelenek her coğrafyada başka bir renge
inanca
dönüşüyor önce hanelere doğuyor Bahar
güneşi Bahar temizliği
başlıyor Bahçeler
süpürülür evler badanalı
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
doğanın güzelliğini evlere taşımak için
semener hazırlanıyor davet edilen
komşularla kutlanıyor
Nevruz sadece yakındakilerle değil
uzaktakiler kaybettikleriyle de kutluyor
insanlar bayramı
[Müzik]
kırlara çıkılıyor hep birlikte Nevruz'u
kutlayanlar kötülükleri döküp baharı
iyiliklerle karşılamak için o gün
kurulan salıncaklarda sallanıyorlar
[Müzik]
yüzlerini
boyuyor sonra derede yıkıyorlar baharın
ilk sularıyla
[Müzik]
çocuklar kapı kapı dolaşıp fındık fıstık
toplayarak oyunlar oynayarak
katılıyorlar nevruz'un paylaşılan ruhuna
[Müzik]
kazanlarla pişiriliyor
yemekler ve sofralara S ve Ş harfleriyle
başlayan 7 nesne konuyor geleneksel
olarak
[Müzik]
hayvanlar daha verimli ve sağlıklı
olsunlar diye akarsulardan getirilen
sularla
[Müzik]
ıslatılıp
danslarla yemeklerle şenliklerle çocuk
oyunlarıyla karşılanıyor Bahar
[Müzik]
h
güç ve kudretin devamlılığı ve yeniden
dirilişin sembolü olarak Demir dövülüyor
[Müzik]
ve akşamın sonunda coşkuyla yakılıyor
nevruz
[Müzik]
ateşi Hastalıklardan ve kederden
kurtulmak için atlanıyor ateşin
üzerinden Mart içeri pireler
dışarı umut dolu inançlarla yaşama
sevinciyle Yeni güne uyanan çiçeklerle
Nevruz gelir yıl yenilenir tabiat
yenilenir insan olmanın gereği eşitlik
kardeşlik paylaşmak gibi tüm güzel
duygular yenilenir